Speaker 1: Okay.
So you ban abortion.
Who funds all these children that women are
forced to carry the term?
She did not have a good answer.
We'll look at it out.
Through the break.
One of the big questions, of course, in the
in the in the aftermath of the Supreme Court
overturning Roe v Wade is grade.
You'll force all these women to have children
that they don't want or don't feel equipped
or don't have the money to have.
Who is going to help the women?
Who's going to pay for the kids?
Because it's not very pro-life to force a
birth and then do nothing for the mother or
the child in that situation.
And in fact, I tweeted about this so sort
of tongue in cheek by saying now that Roe
v Wade and I know that I misspelled Roe, the
voice to text misspelled, that I throw myself
at your mercy now that Roe v Wade has been
overturned.
The right wing will show their devotion to
children by expanding the child tax credit,
funding child care and pre-K, paid maternity
and paternity leave, etc..
I can't wait for them to do it.
And of course, it's tongue in cheek because
they don't plan to do that.
Well, Trump suck up.
Republican governor of South Dakota Kristi
Noem was interviewed over the weekend by Martha
RADDATZ and she was asked, what are you going
to do for these women?
You said they will never be alone.
What exactly does that mean?
Her answer leaves a little bit to be desired.
Speaker 4: But we want to help support these
mothers.
I think we can do better in this country,
making sure that we're walking alongside them
in these situations and making sure that they
do have the type of health care and the support
financially that they need.
Well, look, let's look at that support.
The nonpartisan Commonwealth Fund, a social
policy think tank, says the 14 states that
have the most restrictive abortion laws, including
South Dakota, invest the least in policies
and programs for women and children.
Speaker 2: Right.
What do you mean when you.
Speaker 4: Say these mothers will never be.
Speaker 1: Alone?
Yes.
Speaker 4: Well, I would say that the facts
on the ground are that South Dakota is doing
a lot to coordinate with nonprofits, with
churches, and then also the state in a new
way by launching this website and committing
to in legislative session to support these
mothers is incredibly powerful.
You know, this is a conversation that.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So so far she said we are going to help support
women.
We're going to walk alongside women.
We are doing a lot with churches and we are
going to AU and nonprofits as well.
And they're going to really talk about this
in legislative session.
Wow.
Well, it sounds like it's going to be fine,
doesn't it?
Speaker 4: We have a change now at the federal
level.
The states will be evaluating how they approach
the situation.
Getting health care to mothers, helping them
during a time of crisis is incredibly important.
And these states, remember, Martha, are overwhelmed
right now with other situations that are going
on with what Joe Biden is doing to the energy
prices.
And guys.
Speaker 1: How can you expect south south
Dakota to help the women forced to birth a
child when there's an energy crisis created
by Joe Biden?
Yeah, I mean, South Dakota has to deal with
that.
They can't help the women.
And then here is another.
Oh, and this is also interesting, even though
Kristi Noem says a bunch of times that women
shouldn't be prosecuted for getting an abortion,
she leaves open the door to prosecuting women
who leave the state to get an abortion and
then come back.
Listen to this.
Speaker 4: And just one more question.
What if your constituents travel to another
state to get an abortion right?
You know, that certainly isn't addressed in
our statute today.
And so it's.
Speaker 1: Not addressed in our statute today.
Okay.
That's not a statement of opinion, though.
That's just what it is right now.
Speaker 4: I think that's things that there
be debate about.
Speaker 1: There will oh, there will be debate
about what to do about that.
Speaker 4: Wow.
But also, we're having lots of debates in
South Dakota, how fundamentally our life has
changed the last couple of years, just with
increased costs and inflation and what this
administration is doing to every single family's
budget.
Speaker 1: So understand, she is not saying,
oh, Martha, no, no, no, no.
If someone goes to another state where abortion
is legal and then comes back, obviously we're
not going to do anything about that.
That's not the way the law works.
That's not the way states work.
No, no.
She actually deflects and then talks about
Joe Biden and energy prices.
She's leaving the door open to saying we will
actually try to prosecute women who leave,
go to a state where abortion is legal, have
an abortion, and then come back.
They're going to try.
I'm not saying they will succeed, but they're
going to try.